we're just going to pause a minute to
make sure we're live on youtube
all right
so our speakers today
mayor jim watson lemai jim watson
ottawa police service board chair diane
deans la priest de la comissa of the
service policy dota
deans
ottawa police service chief peter slowly
the chef de polis du cerveza zatawa
peter slowly
we do have
subject matter experts joining us for
the question period and they are
ottawa police service deputy chief steve
bell
acting deputy chief trish ferguson
and cao blair dunker and from the city
we have city manager steve canelacos and
general manager of emergency and
protective services kim ayotte
la chef ajwait par eterime du cerveza
polis otawa trish ferguson a blair
dunker de hijard principal of the
administration
de la ville new zealand director
municipal steve canelacos
i want to begin by acknowledging that
ottawa is built on unseated algonquin
anishinaabe territory
the peoples of the algonquin and ishnavi
nation have lived on this territory for
millennia their culture and presence
have nurtured and continued to nurture
this land
the city of ottawa honors the peoples
and the land of the algonquin and
ishnavi nation
the city of ottawa honors all first
nations inuit and metis people
and their valuable past and present
contributions to this land
thank you to city council for having me
here today to deliver
and to moderate this important update
because
today's briefing will commence with
opening remarks from mayor jim watson
jim watson
mayor watson
uh great uh thank you very much mel
sivaku and good afternoon everyone good
afternoon uh colleagues
i want to welcome my council colleagues
and members of the ottawa police
services board uh to this information
session on the demonstration
we have until about 3 45 and then
the chief and i and steve k are doing
the media availability at 4.
i want to begin by thanking chief slowly
and acting deputy chief patricia
ferguson for their constant efforts to
keep our residents informed including
monday's press conference and the second
one today
more than 2 000 people tuned in to get
answers to their most pressing questions
and to better understand the police
response to this complex and volatile
situation
as i said previously these protests have
been incredibly disruptive and difficult
for our residents it's time for the
protesters to go back to their own
communities we've seen a decrease in the
number of participants and trucks in the
downtown core but there's still a number
of protesters who say they're here to
stay
ops is implementing a demobilization
plan to reduce the protesters footprint
and further contain the disruptions uh
certainly prior to being residential
neighborhoods as was expressed during
monday's press conference the priority
continues to be the safety of our
residents ensuring that the situation
does not escalate
as you know residents are frustrated and
fed up and you were
hearing lots from your residents through
emails and tweets and videos and some
very very frustrated frightened and
angry residents
i just want to remind you and um
the members of the media and public who
are watching this the city human needs
task force continues to work with 311
and one one to support vulnerable
residents who have been impacted by the
demonstrations in
other words some of them have felt
hostage in their own home not able to
get food and i know my office has helped
a couple uh connect with good companions
and the
meals on wheels program but residents
can require social service assistance by
calling 311 or emailing hntf at
ottawa.ca that address again is hntf
ottawa.ca or call 311
i've relayed our residents frustrations
to the prime minister uh during a very
good conversation on monday he expressed
his support to the community and showed
us that rcmp would provide the resources
necessary to help our ops efforts on the
front lines of this response chief
slowly is also will also provide
additional details on his discussions
with rcmp commissioner brenda
lucky i also have spoken to uh mona
fortier the president of treasury board
and deputy portugal
to seek
guidance on how we can help those people
who have lost their job or lost hours as
a result of not being able to open their
store
as you know it's traditionally in a
lockdown area we're technically out of
the lockdown but we're in a another type
of a lockdown so she's looking into that
i spoke to the provincial uh finance
minister peter bethanthobe uh to get
some
information on those provincial programs
to ensure that our residents
particularly in the affected areas
byward market lower town beignet
centertown golden triangle uh and the
like and uh yasser nakhvi who's the
parliamentary assistant to the minister
of public safety i want to commend uh
peter slowly and the ottawa police
service for ensuring the safety of
downtown residents and businesses of the
demonstrators themselves there have been
no deaths and no serious injuries and
that's something that we can't
underestimate or overestimate or over
talk about this is
people are being critical of the the
chief in the city well it's not it's not
a victory the victory is when you don't
have uh
people harmed or in fact killed and i
want to reiterate that the symbols and
acts of hate witness over the last
several years are discussing and do not
align with the values of our community
we stand with those who continue to be
affected by these displays of
anti-semitism racism bigotry homophobia
and hate and we remain united in our
condemnation of this intolerance the
truckers released a statement today that
said it brought a message uh to the
citizens of ottawa as one of empathy we
understand your frustration but those uh
words ring hollow
so um
i do want to pass i believe we're going
to have counselor deans offer some
comments and then we are going to open
it up for questions
so we'll hand it back to the moderator
thank you
thank you mayor
and yes now we'll hear from ottawa
police service board chair diane deans
good afternoon residence colleagues and
staff i want to start by acknowledging
today that we are meeting virtually on
the unseated and unsurrendered territory
of the algonquin anishinaabeg nation
it has been a very long six days in the
nation's capital i want to start by
addressing the residents of ottawa who
have endured these demonstrations for
nearly a week i want you to know that i
understand your frustration and your
anger the behavior that we are seeing in
our community is absolutely unacceptable
as a nation's capital our residents have
seen many demonstrations over the year
over the years but this goes far beyond
what our citizens are accustomed to
we have seen so many unlawful acts from
the constant blaring of horns to
outright harassment of people simply
going about their daily lives this is
not peaceful and many of our residents
do not feel safe
these past several days i have heard
from countless residents and have had
the opportunity to meet with my
colleagues and council members in the
affected areas i have heard of instances
of verbal abuse sexual harassment racism
and bigotry public urination and
defecation property damage and even
fires in our residential neighborhoods
my colleagues have been working
tirelessly to assist residents in the
affected areas and i want to especially
thank all of the downtown councillors
for your advocacy and for your efforts
i have heard from colleagues that they
desperately need more resources for
their community as chair of the police
services board i cannot direct police
operations but i can assist in getting
more resources to date i've signed mou's
to get more police from other
jurisdictions to help in ottawa and i
will continue to help in any way that i
can to get the necessary resources
i've also been in close contact with our
city emergency operations team and have
worked to get a resource line in place
to assist residents in accessing
essential goods and services in the
impacted areas residents needing help
can now call 311 or 211 to connect with
the human needs task force
no one should go without food supplies
medication or other assistance they need
as a result of these protests
so now i want to set out my expectations
for what i and i think
all ottawa residents need to hear from
this briefing this afternoon
we want to hear the current status of
what is happening on the ground in
ottawa today
we want to know how many protesters
remain in the capital
and what the options are to restore calm
we want to hear that our laws and bylaws
will once again be enforced by ottawa
police and bylaw services we want to
hear that no more heavy vehicles will be
allowed into the impacted areas
we want to know how ottawa police and
city staff will better insulate our
residential neighborhoods from the
impacts of these demonstrations
i want to know what resources police and
city staff need from council and the
police board to help ensure the safety
of our communities and the people living
in them
i want to ask the mayor if he will pick
up the phone and call gofundme in the
states direct directly and demand that
they cease and desist sending money to
these unlawful protesters
and perhaps while he's added he could
pick up the phone and ask the prime
minister to do the same we've had some
conversations about perhaps suing
gofundme
but
uh legal action takes time and this is
urgent we need to cut off the pipeline
of funding to these
people that are unlawfully
mercenaries if you will that are
unlawfully protesting and occupying our
communities
i know mr mayor that you have had a
conversation with your federal
counterparts about covering the city and
police costs relating to this
demonstration occupation
i also want to ask if you will seek a
federal relief package for all workers
and businesses and anyone else who has
been financially impacted by these
demonstrations
and i want to
thank chief slowly the executive command
team and all of the officers on the
ground for their dedication during these
challenging times i know the stress and
the pressure under which you have all
been working
i also want to thank steve canalakas the
senior leadership team and all of the
city staff for their work and efforts to
manage this very difficult situation
and i want to assure ottawa residents
that i will continue to work hard to get
the resources we need to return our city
to the peaceful and welcoming home we
all know it to be
finally
i want to say that i am sorry for the
living hell that you are enduring
we live in the nation's capital home of
our democracy we expect protests and
demonstrations but we don't expect this
merci beaucoup thank you very much
language
thank you chair deans
we will now have a chief slowly
who will speak and then we're going to
take a few moments we have a
presentation to load along the chef
peter slowly
mama
thank you very much
mayor watson chair gaines members of the
police services board and ottawa council
i appreciate the opportunity here to
provide information to you
and i welcome the opportunity along with
my command team
to provide the most up-to-date
information on the status of the
demonstration
our operational planning
the intelligence gathering
investigative efforts
people arrested persons charged
plans
to address substantially the public
safety risks associated to the
demonstration
i first however want to speak to the
residents of ottawa
especially those
people who live or work
or need to transit through
the downtown core closest to where
the major elements of the demonstration
have been taking place over the last
week
i spent the last week myself
visiting the officers
talking to the residents
meeting with the business leaders
that includes even today
a full session with the bia
in the market area of the city
this demonstration has been intolerable
unprecedented
the range of illegal
dangerous and unacceptable activities
is beyond the ability to list in the
time that we have here today
and it has had an immeasurable impact on
your lives
your family's lives
the business livelihood of the city
residents have been the victims of
intense noise
threatening behavior
hateful vitriol
that has no place in our city or
anywhere in our country
businesses have had to close
they've lost employees
they've lost their livelihoods
in some cases they've shuttered and
closed
our officers have been pushed to the
limit
they've been injured
they're fatigued beyond my ability to
describe
while i was traveling throughout the
demonstration areas
center town the market lower town sandy
hill over the course of the previous 24
hours
an elderly couple both in wheelchairs
both of them significantly and firm
approached me
they thanked me
for the work the officers have been
providing to them
they implored me to find ways to better
serve and protect them
and they encouraged me to find a way to
end this as safely as possible for
everybody
recognizing the near impossible
circumstances that we're facing in the
city
while i was at city hall visiting our
officers down there who've been doing
the bulk of the negotiations
i saw a married couple and their little
baby daughter literally getting married
they came over and they asked me as as
chief was it safe for them to go home
after their marriage so many
was it safe for their daughter
we spoke at length
they again thanked me and asked me to
pass on those thanks to my officers and
our partners
they again expressed that they knew how
difficult
almost impossible it was for the
circumstances that we and the residents
and the businesses are facing
i saw one of our emergency service unit
officers
literally helping a homeless person to
drink from a bottle of water
while enabling that person to get the
services they need
in the middle
of the demonstration zone with heavy
trucks
heavy noise
heavy diesel
heavy fear all around
these and a thousand other activities
have been taking place
around this city for the past week
while we have made significant progress
in reducing the impacts of the
demonstration
on our residents
on our businesses
on all people in ottawa
and on our service members there remains
an incredible amount of risk
and an incredible amount of work to get
done
i want to thank the members of the
audible police service and our partner
agencies
city of auto work work staff
fire ambulance services
roads oc transpo
i want to thank
our police partners federal provincial
and municipal
i want to thank steve kanilakis for his
leadership as a city manager
for mayor watson
in his leadership chair deans and the
members of our board
i have four core messages to deliver
and then i will start to turn things
over to the rest of the presentation
to the unlawful demonstrators
let me be clear once again
there are consequences
for your behavior
there have been arrests made
there have been charges laid
there are more coming
they will be announced even today
it does not matter how long it takes
we will find those who committed the
criminal acts
we will lay charges against them
and they will face the possibility of
jail as a result of it
there is no statute of limitations for
criminal acts in this country
and there is nowhere you can go in this
country that we cannot find you and
bring you to justice
number two
for those that have significantly
contributed
to the majority of the traffic chaos
that we have endured in this city
including those of you
who live out of province or have
registered your vehicles out of province
indeed out of country
there will be charges pursued against
you
no matter where you're from
for those of you who have committed acts
of hate
hate crimes
and criminal offenses
we will charge you and you will face
prosecution
that includes those who desecrated our
monuments and particularly the cenotaph
there is an active criminal
investigation into the persons involved
in the desecration of the cenotaph
you will hear more later from deputy
chief steve bell on the status of that
investigation
to the residents of ottawa to the
business owners of ottawa
to the people of ottawa we know you're
hurting
we know you want more action
we are escalating our actions
including
enforcement
we're going to do so without
unnecessarily escalating greater public
safety risks
we do not want riots
we can never accept serious injuries or
deaths
but all options remain on the table
today the command team and i are here to
provide you with the most up-to-date
information possible intelligence
information investigation information
operations information
we're going to let you know as clearly
as we can
with the appropriate context
the full nature of the threats the risks
the unlawful conduct
the volatile elements
that this disruptive demonstration has
had and continues to have
as the chair and the mayor mentioned
this is a unique and unprecedented
demonstration
one that is extremely well funded
and one that comes with extensive public
safety lists
this demonstration is local
it affects us here in the nation's
capital
it affects ottawa residents ottawa
business owners
but it is provincial
it is national
and it is increasingly international
we have individuals who have come from
every part of canada here to ottawa
indeed we have ottawa residents
participating in the
demonstrations we are now aware of a
significant element from the united
states
that have been involved in the funding
the organizing
and the demonstrating
they have converged in our city and
there are plans for more to come
is putting our city and our residents
our partners and our officers
at great risk
we are doing our very best to manage
this risk
again
we are grateful for
the fact that there have been no riots
no injuries
and no deaths to date
we cannot rest on any laurels there is
no reason to celebrate in there those
are just facts
but there have been a lot of trauma
and a lot of troubles
hoisted on this city
we are arrested
we are charging
we are investigating all bad actors
all criminals
enforcement will continue
all options are on the table
this has truly become a whole of service
whole of community
whole of city
and increasingly whole of country effort
we have been working with all three
levels of government including all three
levels of policing and public safety
agencies municipal police services
provincial police services
the federal police service rcmp
national security agencies increasingly
our border agencies
all options for the resolution of this
demonstration are on the table
from a negotiated resolution to an
enforced resolution
let me be clear
all such options come with significant
risk
risk to rioting
risk to injury and risk to death
not only are we deploying all available
audible police resources every day
but we have also received requested and
received additional officers and
resources
from the rcmp
the opp and many other municipal police
agencies across ontario
we have gathered together some of the
top policing experts and public safety
experts
including the top public order
commanders in the province and federally
to explore
and prepare a range of options
to end this demonstration as safely and
effectively as we possibly can
we are monitoring demonstrations that
are taking place across this country
from british columbia to alberta to
quebec
and beyond
i have been in contact within the last
24 hours with rcmp commissioner brenda
lucky
specifically in regards to the
demonstration that is taking place
in alberta near the border
in a small town of 240 people
for those of you that have been
following that particular demonstration
you can see that the very first attempt
to enforce an end to that demonstration
was unable to do so
created immediate public safety risks
it included
vehicles being driven towards
the officers
dangerous collisions resulting from that
and the immediate
refilling of the spaces that were
cleared in the initial efforts
all of which
are elements that we're facing here
the scale and the complexity and the
danger exponentially more so in that
particular location
i truly hope for the safety of all
police officers first responders
residents
in that town they're faced with
an extremely difficult and dangerous
situation there
and we're hearing about similar
demonstrations that are underway
or planned to be underway in the very
near future across this country
shortly deputy chief ferguson will lay
out the current situation
explain our resourcing
and our approach as we move forward
she will talk about the daily efforts we
are making to contain this demonstration
to negotiate
as best we can a reduction in the
impacts that we've been having over the
last several days to move demonstrators
into places
that have less effect on residential and
business areas and to lessen the impact
on the overall city
our intent from the beginning of all
such negotiations is just that to bring
to a full end of the demonstration
again i stress
we have very little ability to negotiate
with all aspects of the demonstration
there are multiple multiple stakeholders
and players and organizations involved
in this
many of whom have no intent despite our
best efforts to engage in any form of
communication coordination never mind
negotiation
deputy chief ferguson will explain our
efforts to redeploy officers away from
the core demonstration
into the market lower town sandy hill
centertown and other affected areas
neighborhood resource team officers
crime prevention officers community
safety officers
our public order officers to provide as
much visibility
service and safety
coordination and cooperation with the
local residents and businesses
that started yesterday it is escalated
overnight into today and will continue
to do so until and if we need those
resources to rejoin the core of the
demonstration
deputy chief bell will describe the
multiple arrests that have already taken
place
the ongoing intelligence gathering and
threat assessments the ongoing
investigations including the
investigation into the criminal activity
at the national war memorial
multiple investigations have been
launched
but we know that there are more reports
of criminality that have not come to us
you will hear again and again in this
presentation the need for residents and
business owners who've been victimized
by hate or by crime
to report these to our hotlines that
information will be presented very
shortly
our chief administration officer officer
blair dunker will lay out the financial
impacts to date the costs of these
demonstrations
on the police service i cannot imagine
the full costs on the lives of our
residents the business owners
and the overall city of ottawa
i said this week
and i said last week all options for
resolution are on the table
we are continually looking at our
options and developing scenarios to end
this demonstration as safely as possible
while charging and holding those who
committed crimes to account
the more this demonstration continues
the more the risk to public safety
increases
every option is on the table to resolve
this demonstration
that said
there may not be a policing solution to
this demonstration
i will now turn things over to acting
deputy chief ferguson to provide a more
in-depth overview of the current
operations
so i'd like to outline for you right now
our current
situation the ottawa police service and
our partners have been operational 24 7
since this event began and have managed
to ensure zero injuries zero riots and
zero deaths
while it is impossible to accurately
state
and as we estimate that there were
between eight and fifteen thousand
people and thousands of trucks that
formed the demonstration when it was at
its peak on saturday afternoon
we have made significant progress in
reducing this number and with patient
negotiations we find ourselves with
several hundred
trucks in the city
most demonstrators have left
what remains is a highly determined and
highly volatile group of unlawful
individuals
beyond the core footprint
residents and businesses remain severely
impacted
and there are significant
ongoing social and economic costs
the next slide will be a map
and you will see
the outline here of the footprint i will
tell you that successful negotiations by
our police liaison team has resulted in
cooperation with some truck operators
and has led to the reopening of some key
roadways and bridges most recently the
shoddy air bridge
that said many roads in the downtown
core remain obstructed or closed
residents in the area will notice that
the core footprint
is being hardened with barricades
replacing some of the heavy trucks that
were used on the weekend
this is in large part due to the
upcoming weather forecast and the fact
that this machinery will be required for
other purposes
if you look at the map you'll see the
green areas represent areas roadways
that have been reopened since saturday
the red areas represent
where they're closed uh or have very
limited access to them
and you'll see in the yellow marks areas
where there's one-way traffic only
i want to stress that the results and
opening up routes are due to dogged and
patient negotiations with demonstration
organizers and individual truck
operators and these are ongoing
i will now turn it over to dc bill
my apologies i believe i was on mute um
so good afternoon everyone thanks for
having us here today uh and thank you
trish for the opening i'm going to take
the opportunity to give you a briefing
around our intelligence and
investigative efforts to date as well as
an update on where we currently sit in
terms of an intelligence
idea around what the next coming days is
going to look like
so i can let you know that from the
start of the convoy we've continued to
gather intelligence on the progress of
it
we continue to work with our partners in
the rcmp and opp to gather
and disseminate real-time intelligence
information that is supporting our
operations on an ongoing basis
uh from this we know that there remains
uh many unlawful demonstrators that are
highly determined and highly volatile
within our city
we're now somewhere between a
demonstration and a longer term effort
to occupy our streets
what we're seeing currently is that on
the weekends past weekend coming weekend
we're seeing an increase in demonstrate
demonstration
based activities and during the week
we're seeing an attempt an effort to
occupy our streets and clog congestion
and movement
uh the intelligence that we're seeing
currently is telling us that we will
continue to see the convoy attempt to
hold the footprint that they have
we expect to see increased vehicular
traffic in the downtown core beginning
on saturday increasing over the weekend
again anticipated to decrease come
monday
we're seeing several protesters again
this weekend who intend to attend the
area on foot and our information that
we're gathering indicates that we'll see
large groups of people gathering in the
parliamentary precinct who are both in
support of the convoy efforts as well as
opposed to them and they will all be
demonstrating within the same area
downtown
we anticipate that these unlawful
demonstrations of people on our streets
will will again
occur right through the weekend
these demonstrations present a serious
and ongoing risk to public safety that
we continue
to
evaluate and manage on an ongoing basis
many of the organizers and people
present have stated a purpose to incite
violence and and spread hatred and our
officers are doing everything they can
in their power to stop that from
happening
every enforcement effort that we are
taking and they are considerable has to
be weighed against the risk to incite
violence
we will continue to gather disseminate
and evaluate the intelligence to assist
in our operational planning and we will
monitor it and continually provide
updates on the picture that we're seeing
as we've said from the beginning if we
go to the next slide please as we said
from the beginning any unlawful and
illegal activity will not be tolerated
in our city
we're leveraging all means that we have
to gather information and intelligence
to assess the ongoing risk and identify
quickly criminal activity today i can
report to you that three men have been
charged with criminal offences to date
one with uttering threats
one with carrying a weapon to a public
meeting and one with mischief under five
thousand dollars all of those charges
have been processed and are before the
courts we continue to have 25 active
investigations that we conduct
investigations into
uh including the desecration of the war
memorial and the incidents at the
shepherds of good hope
we are we continue to receive dozens of
uh pieces of information through the two
hotlines that we've set up and that and
they continue to be investigated by our
hate crimes unit if there is or hate
time to report please do report it to
our hate crimes hotline and if there is
a criminal incident to report please
report it to our
criminal hotline at extension 7300
i can't overemphasize the focus that
we're placing on our criminal
investigations our entire criminal
investigations chain of command has been
focused towards this effort we
continually in an ongoing basis are
conferring with our crown attorneys who
have provided amazing support to us to
assist in culminating investigations and
laying charges and we will continue to
do that work
we want to continue to utilize
investigators and evidence gatherings
teams to pursue charges against anyone
who is committing an illegal act within
our city
the intelligence networks that we've
been utilizing also have given us have
given us strong insights into the
reigning bad actors that we're
continuing continuing to deal with in
our city
i indicated we can go to the next slide
please as i indicated before we've
placed a focus on reporting over the
last number of days ottawa police
service is very fortunate to have some
of the best investigators
including hate crimes investigators in
the country
we know the impact that this is having
and continues to have on our community
we want you to know that we are here for
you to receive your reports to protect
your interests and to to look to
prosecute anyone involved in criminal
activity
we need people to report you have two
numbers here
that have are identified as numbers that
you can call to expedite reporting and
if there's a crime in progress you can
call 911. it is exceptionally important
that our residents who have witnessed or
been a victim of any illegal activity
any illegal behavior whether big or
small
report it to the police
we have we've set up formal and informal
channels in order to be able to receive
this information and we can't implore on
our community enough there is no
incident too small to report to us we
have the teams we have the investigators
and we have the people set up to conduct
these investigations
we'll continue to push our message out
around reporting and ask that anyone who
knows of somebody who has
experienced
challenging or criminal activity during
this protest to please encourage them to
report it to the ottawa police service
i'll now turn it over to deputy chief
ferguson to provide an overview of our
enforcement efforts
thank you steve
um i'd like to start by acknowledging
the immense cooperation and help that
we've had from our law enforcement and
intelligence partners
they've been generous with their time
expertise and personnel
the crest depicted on this slide lets
you know that ottawa residents have
support from across the province and
indeed the country
ottawa residents have endured nearly a
week of disruptions and unlawful and
sometimes downright despicable human
behavior
they are rightfully fed up
and we hear you
we've been deploying hundreds of
officers daily with significant
contributions from our policing partners
we are now in what i would describe as a
period of stabilization
we have adequate resourcing in place in
the immediate area adjacent to
parliament hill
and we have now freed up officers over
the last 24 hours to deploy into
impacted neighborhood areas
as of last night our officers have begun
stricter enforcement outside of the
immediate demonstration vicinity
officers and bylaw officers are now
actively addressing traffic and noise
violations as well as any reported
incidents in impacted neighborhoods
our community officers have been
involved in daily contact with bias and
residents
and with information from a local
councillor
two of them were able to make were made
aware of a truck that was idling outside
a child care center on king edward and
that trucker's actions were preventing
the kids from being able to go outside
a conversation with our officers put an
end to that behavior
there have literally been hundreds of
those types of interactions that our
officers have been engaging in over the
last six days and we intend to continue
with this approach
it's a measured approach and it's
representative of the rapidly evolving
and volatile situation
heavier focus on addressing driving
violations are now taking place in the
downtown core and our traffic officers
who were tied up with the demonstration
are now back
addressing those issues
next slide please
i will turn this now over to
ceo ms dunker
hi
um
[Music]
so we are tracking costs related to
enforcement and the management of the
ongoing demonstrations
our costs are currently coming in at
approximately 800 000 per day and that's
in direct costs and those costs are
growing
as we record and tabulate them and
receive invoices
this is in addition
obviously to the many things that have
been spoken about the economic and the
social impacts related to the unlawful
demonstrations
so to date we have well over 3 million
in tabulated costs and growing
and to give you some contacts some
context for that the seven year average
uh for the canada day celebrations was
approximately 620 000
and canada 150
cost 1.44 million
so this event the costs in in not this
event but this demonstration are
significant and the ops itself is
already facing significant pressures
this fiscal year as many of us know
uh and we have no ability to manage
these costs so at some point we will be
turning to the federal and the municipal
governments for support uh to offset
these significant and growing costs
with that i'll turn it back over to
deputy chief ferguson and she's going to
give us a sense of what we may expect in
terms of as we move towards the weekend
thanks
thank you blair
so turning our mind to the weekend we
are anticipating additional
demonstrators will be arriving in town
the numbers we have not yet got a full
picture of
we will have the resources necessary to
respond
and as deputy bell spoke of
investigators and evidence gathering
teams will be in place to find and
charge illegal behavior
we expect the weather may be difficult
but our goal is to keep everyone safe
and finally i'd like to speak to some of
the myths and disinformation currently
on social media the police have not and
will not provide material to support the
demonstrators
this community has demanded their police
service be professional and measured in
everything we do
and i would take this opportunity to
tell the community and remind some in it
that measured and professional is
exactly what we are doing as we face
this current event
insinuating our members have sinister
motives only serves to fuel an already
divisive narrative
and quite frankly it adds an unnecessary
burden on our members and i would
respectfully ask on be on their behalf
that this is stopped
we all share the goal of ending this
protracted event
thank you we'll see
thank you
we will now be going to the question
period
so i will be inviting counselors and
board members who have questions
to ask one question we want to be able
to give everyone an opportunity to speak
if there is time we will address
follow-up questions
silly
we will start with a question from the
mayor and then we'll win we will invite
councillors from ward 1 to 23 beginning
with ward one
counselors will be able to turn on their
camera when asking their questions
a lot more time for my colleagues thank
you okay
thank you sir
so we'll start with ward one counselor
lula do you have a question
yes and thank you very much
i appreciate the update we're on day six
of this occupation
people in the city are very angry and
i'm certain that if we do not see some
real tangible changes in the approach
being taken that individual citizens
and i worry about this
will begin to take matters into their
own hands this is an even more dangerous
situation than what we are seeing now
i'm hearing reports that there have been
attempted break-ins harassment and
assaults and residents are reporting it
but these calls have allegedly been
brushed off due to the force's inability
to respond
due to the ongoing occupation and lack
of resources pita pill are having
trouble sleeping
they do not feel safe in their own homes
which is the only refuge they have left
in this pandemic
and understanding my background i don't
ask this question lightly
and i understand that we are living in a
tim in a tinderbox here in the nation's
capital
but what is the plan moving forward and
how long will this be allowed to go on
before the gradual use of force is
considered thank you
councillor thank you very much i'll
invite deputy chief bell to respond to
the specific questions about reporting
levels of reporting that we've received
so far and responses to it
let me first of all just remind
the mayor and council
and the board
we are not waiting to consider the use
of enforcement we have been
enforcing you've just heard a briefing
we have made a number of arrests we are
laying charges
um that has been ongoing and will
continue in the weeks and months and
potentially years after this event is
over
we are not waiting to start planning
around the use of enforcement to remove
some or all portions of the
demonstration
those plans were underway when we
realized that that large demonstration
was in fact moving across the country
coming towards ontario in ontario and
now in the city the plan
to use all options
remains on the table from the first day
as it will to the last day i will ask
deputy chief bell now to speak very
specifically around the number of
criminal complaints we've received the
process that is used once a complaint is
made
and again i i urge all residents to
actually report
those incidents to the police reporting
them on twitter
talking about it to your counselor does
not allow us to commence a criminal
investigation
deputy bell
thank you chief and thank you councillor
law for your question
um so i'm gonna i'm gonna start it where
the chief ended off we we have to have
people or we're actually imploring our
community to report incidents that that
they're being engaged in we've received
25 reports of criminal activity to date
that we have investigators following up
on and investigating
we have a dedicated team of
investigators to look at our criminal
matters and we have a dedicated team of
investigators to look at all of our hate
crime issues
so reporting is key to us uh in relation
to us not responding or taking calls
i've received no information of that to
date but if you do have specific
issues that you can provide to us we'll
make sure to take the complaint as well
as rectify any of those reporting
streams we're working really hard with
our members to identify
streams and ways to get information into
our organization and then into the hands
of our investigators so they can
immediately start the investigations
into these matters so again it is
exceptionally important we need people
to report incidents we know how
challenging this has been for our
community and how much our community
hurts around it we are here to enforce
the laws but when complaints are made we
will conduct a criminal investigation
thank you
we will now move to ward 2
councillor dudas do you have a question
avivu in question
thank you for this briefing and for this
opportunity to ask questions on behalf
of my residents and many other residents
across the city
i understand fully that as politicians
we cannot direct the outward police
service
however i need you to clearly understand
that from one corner of the city to the
other the sentiment is unanimous that
this occupation of our city needs to end
the perception that i've been hearing
from residents and i've spoken to
hundreds of them
is that the lack of obvious and strong
action is condoning the illegal
activities that have occurred and it
only opens the door up further for a
disregard of our laws our regulations
and our city's values
we've seen that residents in the court
are starting to take matters into their
own hands
which is a threat to their own safety
and it clearly demonstrates a sense of
frustration and abandonment
the damage that this occupation has done
to our city the massive impacts on
downtown residents the concerns that
they have for their safety and not to
mention the financial implications on
our downtown businesses let alone our
own city's coffers this it absolutely
has to end
chief you said that all options on are
on the table
you mentioned that fully but when can we
as council as residents even as our
police force when can we expect to get
our city back
thank you counselor
i share your frustrations as you've
shared them from your constituents
let me be clear
the people that came for this
demonstration
did not come to the city of ottawa for
the city of ottawa
they did not come seeking your
permission or my permission
they're not coming to seek an audience
with you or me
global pandemic has been affecting
this city this province this country and
everywhere
for almost two years
there are people from across this
country and as we're now understanding
other countries
we've come here to express some form of
frustration
with all forms of government activity in
regards to the
pandemic
and quite frankly in regards to just
about anything else that government does
at municipal provincial and federal
levels
i have an oath of office
i hold an office that is responsible for
providing safe
adequate and effective policing to the
residents of this city
i am doing my very best my members are
doing their very best
in every interaction whether in a
demonstration or outside of one
our actions have to be lawful
they have to be proportionate to the
risk
and they really should not create even
more risk having done so
this council
our board
have been very clear around the need to
act lawfully ethically and in
proportionate to the risks that we're
facing
the law requires the same thing
in my comments when i started
i was clear as you've been clear the
longer this goes on
the more risk there are associated to it
this is not just a local ottawa
demonstration
there are similar demonstrations taking
place in many other parts of this
country indeed many other parts around
this continent in the world
what happens here affects there
what happens there affects here
we have seen in the last 24 hours
attempts by other police and other
jurisdictions to do just what you have
suggested
they were not effective
and they created additional safety
issues
potential life-threatening safety issues
i have great compassion for those that
have been significantly affected if not
traumatized and we know
criminally victimized
we will do everything we can to hold
those who've done that to account we'll
continue arresting and charging people
as we have been
but any action taken without
understanding the totality of the
context the totality of the risk
would be irresponsible
you're trying to be responsible lawful
ethical
and measured
my last comment when i wrapped up i'll
share again now
the longer this goes on
the more i am convinced there may not be
a police solution to this demonstration
there are police chiefs commissioners
across this country that are dealing
with demonstrations that are starting
underway and significantly advanced
this is a national issue
not an ottawa issue as the ottawa police
chief i will continue to do my members
will continue to do their very best to
keep the city as safe as possible in
these unique and unprecedented
circumstances
ward 3. amy it's diane deans i'm just
wondering um if it would be possible to
allow the two counselors in the most
impacted area counselor catherine
mckenney and then counselor matthew
flurry if they could ask their questions
next with the
with the agreement of the rest of
council they are in the you know eye of
the storm and i think it would be
um
it would be good of counsel to allow
them to ask their questions early on in
this briefing
yes i'm sure we can do that so you'd
like it to be captured mckinney first
and then councillor fleury is that right
yes please thank you i want to make sure
i have the right order yes we can do
that
so
i will ask a counselor mckinney
if you can ask your question please
thank you can you hear me
thank you uh chair deans i i appreciate
that uh
allowing me to to go next um
there are there are two lines of
confrontation in this city there is what
is happening on the hill on wellington
the main occupation
and then there's what is happening in
our residential neighborhoods
and i hear
no urgency
today
to what is happening to residents
in their neighborhood
it is not
just disruptive and difficult
it is
violent
and terrorizing
and it is targeting residents
in their homes near their homes as they
walk down their street
and residents downtown have been
abandoned
during a national crisis and an
occupation of our city
and i can
i can i can respect that what's
happening on the hill
is volatile
and i can respect that
the response to that i don't
i am not i don't profess to be
an expert in policing
crowd control riot control and i and i i
respect
that i don't have advice on how
that mob is
um
it is managed
but when we when we think about what is
happening south of wellington
it is
it is impacting residents
what they want to see
and and i and i appreciate counselor
deans um
mentioning that the task force you know
can be sent out
to provide you know necessities for
people
but what we need we need
the federal rcmp to take over the full
lead for what is happening
on parliament hill and wellington
you can request that the mayor chief of
police you can request it and i beg you
to request it
having the net the neighborhood response
teams back into residential
neighborhoods when they are under siege
is not enough
they are left to themselves
it cannot continue this is not a
judgment on one force over another
what it is is a plea
a plea
that you recognize as our local police
force
that you owe it to our residents to be
there
full time that you hand over the lead i
understand there will still be some
members of the police service on the
hill but that you hand over the lead
to the rcmp and that you turn all of
your attention
to what's happening in our community
women
are being violently harassed
seniors cannot go into the grocery store
without being yelled at
people want to see
drivers stop it's one at a time this is
not mobs what's happening in in our
residential neighborhoods is not mobs
it's one car one truck
honking horns driving down sidewalks
children trying to get to school people
are terrified it's
constant honking it is terrorizing
residents need to move around they need
it every day so this is not just about
extra resources
this is about you turning your attention
to the people
that you're meant to serve
i've written to you
with my colleague
counselor fleury asking
that you request that the rcmp come onto
the hill and take
take control
and when this is over i'm gonna i'm
telling you and residents of this city
that i'm writing myself to the prime
minister
and to the commissioner the rcmp lucky
and i'm going to ask
i'm going to beg them
to take over what's happening on the
hill so that our local police service
can turn its attention
to the people in this city who are being
terrorized in their neighborhood
i don't think that i can express enough
what is happening i know we don't want
riots there are already riots happening
it is happening happened on laurier last
night people are terrified
they're terrified and there are no
there's no presence of police it just it
has to it has to has to change
so i'm going to leave it at that i've
asked you earlier if you were going to i
didn't get a clear answer
um
but i'm going to tell you that that i
will turn my attention and to and for
the residents of this city to know that
i will turn my attention to
begging the federal government
to come in and take over what's
happening on the hill
thank you
thank you very much counselor um and as
we discussed on the call when we're
wrong with the bia
um it's too bad that we didn't have a
chance to speak yesterday when i reached
out to you i suspect you're incredibly
busy looking after constituents and i
know that's your priority
i didn't get i didn't get a message from
you it must have been a mistake but i'm
not saying you didn't but i did i just
certainly did not ignore you i i i
certainly suspect it was a mistake but
uh wasn't from a lack of attempt in my
part to engage you on these very very
topical issues and as you have been
briefed by me i think this will be the
third time this week and we've had a
chance to get in depth so i appreciate
the lines of communication are very
strong and very open and that we've had
many conversations over the last week
and will continue to do so no doubt so
thank you counselor i'm going to very
shortly ask uh acting deputy chief
ferguson to provide a much deeper
briefing than she was able to in the
initial part around what we have done in
the last 24 hours what activities have
been taking place and what will continue
to happen over the next several days
depending on whether or not we get back
into a large scale demonstration as i've
said to you and others on this call i'm
in daily contact with commissioner
brenda lucky we actually just sent the
latest staffing request over to her and
i just heard back that staffing request
includes the provision of public order
units additional public order units on
top of what she's been able to
generously provide already investigators
intelligence analysts supervisors
traffic control officers
i think you know uh councillor that the
rcmp
although in the tens of thousands has
policing jurisdictions for the national
capital region
for several provinces contract policing
northern remote uh territorial policing
international policing peacekeeping and
force protection for embassies around
the world they are probably
more underfunded than the ottawa police
services and they are probably extremely
overstretched they have been very
generous but they do not have unlimited
resources they are also not the police
of jurisdiction here and we have invited
them and they have accepted invitation
to be part of our instant command
program they're part of our
constellation of public sector national
security
uh private sector agencies that form
intercept and they've been involved in
the planning the intelligence and the
operations from the very beginning and
they will continue to do so
what you're talking about is
transitioning
the lead role from the audible police to
the rcmp
um that's not jurisdictionally possible
what we want to focus on and what we are
focusing on and what we have been
focusing on is increasing the amount of
resources you can move from the
demonstration into the immediately
affected areas which obviously includes
your constituent area and i'll turn
things over to deputy chief ferguson to
continue on with providing additional
information as to what we're doing thank
you
thank you chief and thank you councillor
um
your constituents are lucky to have you
and you make a very um impassioned and
um
you know
very wonderful case on their behalf um
i'd like to try and explain what we have
been uh attempting to do
um and i'll start by saying our very
stretched resources are now being
asked to stretch a little bit more
our members have been uh working 24 7.
and it's only really in large part in
the last couple of days due to help from
outside agencies that we've been able to
now turn our mind to what you're asking
us to do and what is expected of us and
we know that it hurts our members
to to not be able to address all the
things they signed up each and every one
of them to to do in this city was to
serve people and especially our most
vulnerable
um
so i can tell you that the the nrt uh
teams we have taken them now from quick
response teams addressing issues in
in the the footprint of the
demonstration to now spreading out into
your ward councillor flurries ward
council menard's ward to address some of
the folks who are most impacted by this
and we're prioritizing as we go with
things like our vulnerable
community residents
our homeless shelters those places where
we know that we are needed most
our goal is going to be to reduce
the perception of disorder and the
actual activities that that
lead to disorder in neighborhoods we are
going to be looking to promote community
safety and well-being
preventing crime and disorder protecting
our vulnerable
creating a flow of vital intelligence on
a range of issues relating to the
protest we'll be speaking to people
gathering whatever information they they
are able to share
and looking to reduce crime and
victimization on a large scale
we will be highly visible
with a focus on customer service problem
solving and ensuring that our members
will continue to provide the duty of
care that they already do to this
community in the way that they want to
what i will say though is if we don't
hear from residents we don't know what's
going on
and it has already been addressed uh by
a number of the speakers but
mentioning it to
you know the i spoke about the truck on
king edward that was because the
counselor shared that with the local
community police officer there are
easier ways to report people can call
you know all of our
numbers they can report online if
they're concerned
but we need to hear from you for us to
be able to do things and we we we are
now in a position where we are able to
and willing and and going to get our
boots on the ground in the areas that
you need us in
so i i appreciate the question and the
the
very difficult um and traumatizing
situation some of our residents have put
been living through
and
so we will be doing our very best now to
address that as as much as we can and
we're thankful for all the help that
we've got especially with our city
partners who have also been helping
because some of these are are issues
that they can help with as well
thank you
i'll now ask
councillor fleury from ward 12
to ask your question
can you hear me
yes i can go ahead okay
[Music]
uh i want to thank uh all colleagues i
want to thank local businesses i want to
thank local residents for um
for staying engaged for sharing
information
um
i i know there's a lot of media
listening on and i think it's important
to address this matter
there are really two ottawas there's the
ottawa and the responsibility of the
national government and federal precinct
there's also the local ottawa
and when councilors like me speak we're
speaking on behalf of our residents in
our neighborhoods businesses in our
neighborhoods
and it's been extremely difficult to
share what we're
what we're facing and what we're seeing
with all the the noise that's happening
on uh social media platforms and
on national coverage of uh such the
situation and the occupation in ottawa i
i want to
bring you to that my community keeps
raising saying
how come these real stories aren't being
shared how come they're not taking us
seriously in our community and the
impacts that we're hearing
is
public safety in our neighborhoods as
you've heard from a friend and colleague
catherine
are
my other most at
focus right now we're hearing uh
residents wanting to take the bus and
issues of safety going to the bus we're
hearing kitchen staffs leaving
their their their work and being
harassed to take the lrt at rito
where uh residents feel hostage in their
own home with the the noise the yelling
the intimidation they the hate crimes
they're scared they go out they're
scared they're in their house they're
scared the noise is
unbearable uh six days of honking
non-stop early day late night all day
rito center being closed i don't know
for those of you counselors and
colleagues like me and for those in the
media closing the radio center can you
imagine that the riddle center has been
closed since saturday afternoon
they've now confirmed that they will
remain closed until february 6th
just think of that as a
the economic small business
commercial spaces of our city and all
the links that are tied into that when
you think of small locally owned
businesses on rito street and in the
broward market and how this has
increasingly negatively impacted their
ability to operate
they've made
they've made decisions many to close
because they fear
so i'm asking you chief and authorities
what are you doing to provide proactive
and visible policing security for
residents and businesses in my community
specifically outside of the federal
precinct
in my community at cerritos street
byward market and council mckinney's
area it's in centertown we're not in
competition
we're working together but we do we do
feel the same uh the same concerns from
residents and businesses and we want to
make sure that
local public safety is other most of
mine i will ask sub questions to that
very briefly and then i will not come
back on
are you having dialogues as you've
described with policing and public
safety are you encouraged by that
do you have enough boots on the ground
as it relates to rcmp and opp do you
have enough resources uh chief and ops
those are questions that i continue to
get from residents and want
clarification on so thank you for uh
thank you counselor chair dean for uh
giving the space for councillor uh kenny
and i to uh
to to uh to raise our questions and
obviously we have so many more to ask
thank you uh counselor again uh uh echo
previous comments you're speaking
eloquently and passionately about the
needs and frustrations and victimization
of your your constituents including the
business group and i appreciate the
opportunity to meet with yourself the
mayor
councillor mckinney and the bias down in
the market area
for an hour this morning
discussing the range of issues and
again great expressions from leaders
with business leaders small and
medium-sized employers
people who've lived in this
city all their lives including one
business owner whose
father was a member of the audible
police service for over 30 years a great
deal of understanding and compassion
about what we're all facing here and our
mutual commitment to get to a better
place as quickly and safely as possible
i will once again ask uh acting deputy
chief ferguson to provide
uh answers to your specific questions uh
in regards to the levels of police
services
available to your
uh and council mckinney's awards
trish if you're able to go again through
the information
certainly and i think council flurry um
i think you've been working as hard as a
lot of our members uh standing up for
your residents and advocating on their
behalf and
and while i am very appreciative of the
the information sharing again i would
just like to remind constituents that
they can uh report to us directly uh and
and it will assist us in in streamlining
uh their their needs and
how we can get officers there as quickly
as possible
um i think you're aware of of
the cpos and just how effective those
community police officers are and you
have a couple of fantastic officers in
your zones um and
they are a great conduit for certainly
for the business um community to to
leverage and to share uh their their
pressing issues most of them are quite
similar and something that we can you
know develop a plan uh in going forward
and we we have been working on how we're
going to address that
you will see the the neighborhood
resource teams will be uh coming into
your your neighbors into your
neighborhoods
we have upwards
over 20 officers that we will be
deploying
they started last night they they hit
over two dozen businesses and
residents going in to speak to people
obviously it takes time and we know that
right now people have a lot to say about
it and they're there to listen uh to
gather information and to build uh
intelligence and share that back into
our organization um or to our our city
partners if it's something that needs to
be addressed by by another service and
we will look to leverage those as well
so
i know it it seems it's it's a slow
process we have had to really make sure
that we had um the downtown core um
[Music]
solidified and and protected and i think
we are as of yesterday in a pretty good
situation again it's a measure approach
and
you will see now that they will be going
out and addressing what they can in
terms of
do we have enough resources
we will always uh benefit from from more
resources or more partners and so the
the magic of the community police
officers is one of them is worth uh you
know 10 officers because they're problem
solvers and they are
able to you know connect quickly because
they have those relationships that are
already built so
i want to thank them for that and i
think we will we will continue to
leverage them and try and magnify the
impact that they have in your area
so thank you
chair deans
we do have a hard stop at 3 45
so i'm wondering if you could give us
some direction as to
what other counselors
yeah and there are board members there
are board members on the call too maybe
as well
council menard is also in an impacted
area and has kindly asked for permission
to go next and then after that i would
just say to my council colleagues and
board colleagues um if if you don't have
a pressing question maybe you could just
yield the floor to the next person
because i know there are a lot of
questions and just to everyone if you
could be very concise
in asking your questions so that
everybody that wants an opportunity gets
one
okay thank you
so we'll resume with councillor menard
and we'll go back to the order
so councillor bernard
if you would like to ask a question
please yes thank you very much and thank
you uh to chair jeans as well this is in
my ward too um it's not nearly as much
as council fleury and kelsey mckinney's
but it is here
so i'll be concise in my question um
the main question i have is is how are
you
specifically
keeping the large trucks
from going into residential
neighborhoods
and how are you preventing more large
trucks from going into our downtown
taking up more space
this weekend
where does a court injunction stand and
are you setting deadlines for those
trucks in the residential areas with
strict fines
if they remain thank you
councilmart thank you as a resident in
your award i can appreciate you
representing my interests as well as the
rest of everybody else's
interests
i'll ask chris ferguson to speak to the
traffic plan for the weekend shortly
i can confirm
we reached out to the city legal
services city manager
last week to initiate discussions
uh included a briefing to our board
board chair
to initiate discussions around the
seeking of an injunction the city would
have to lead that injunction process
we and other agencies would support that
injunction application by way of
information
i can tell you that as of today there
was a meeting between our legal services
team my general counsel christian hino
and the legal services team of the city
to continue the injunction application
process i've said before i'll say it
again all options are on the table
including the pursuit of an injunction
to address some significant if not all
parts of the demonstration
with that i'll turn things over to
acting deputy chief ferguson to talk
about the traffic plan for what we can
so far to intelligence anticipate that's
coming to the city
thank you chief and thank you council
bernard
so our traffic officers um as you
probably anybody who follows their
twitter handle knows how effective they
they are when they turn their minds to
specific um
incidents and so um we have asked them
to turn some attention to the idling and
the
driving infractions which we have seen
an increase of i was just getting
numbers this morning from our folks and
they are they are definitely out there
and um and laying down um you know the
rules of the road for for all those such
incidents uh in terms of our ability to
limit
people moving around in the street we do
not have authority to prevent
you know trucks from going into
certain areas now obviously we have
truck routes in this city and those are
the types of
highway traffic act things that we can
enforce uh but we're not able to
necessarily shut down streets per se uh
and prevent people from being able to to
to travel and circulate through those
that's just not a right that uh
that obviously this public is willing to
give up nor should they so
our traffic folks will um
will continue to enforce um for noise
for um you know driving infractions for
hta violations uh they're working right
now with some by-law officers um and
obviously we know that this has to be a
measured approach because um we are
seeing as we do with just regular
citizens when they get a traffic ticket
uh it's obviously evokes quite a lot of
emotion and sometimes anger and we have
to do this in a measured and an approach
that's not going to put any of our
members at risk or any of these uh
truckers at risk but we are working and
will diligently continue to enforce the
rules of the road
okay thank you i just urge whatever
action we can to get those trucks off
the residential roads whether that's
barriers in place for local traffic only
or whatever we need to do it that's the
number one complaint we're getting is
the debilitating noise of trucks going
through those residential areas and
that's what i'm really trying to hem in
or stop uh any way we can thank you very
much
thank you
we will continue going through our
awards
so we will now go with ward 3 counselor
harder if you have a question
sorry
sorry it takes a while for you to get
allowed back in
often you know this council um
does not speak with one voice
uh today we do and uh together we um
are uh united in expressing our
solidarity to condemn these actions and
i have a question for you
uh chief you said that you know that
this weekend your intelligence tells you
this weekend
that the
more trucks are coming into town they'll
be added to the convoy there'll be a
different perhaps action on the hill my
question to you is because
you saying that
leads me to believe and i'm sure others
that there's no action to stop what's
happening now before the weekend
and that is very frightening and my
question is
why are you not looking at stopping this
new traffic coming into our city why are
you not looking at putting barriers up
at the antrim truck stop
at the highway 7 on the 416 on highway
31 and the 417
why are you not doing that why not stop
them that way and why not give the
people who are most affected
in our city hope
uh that uh the days of um the tyranny um
put upon them
well we're coming to an end
thank you
thank you council harder
i think you've heard me on different
occasions
um certainly even before i came here as
chief
for very complex issues
there is never a silver bullet solution
um
i'll be quite clear and i'd stand to be
corrected by by those who are lawyers
but the lawyers who advise me have been
very clear there is nothing within the
charter of rights that would allow
any police and jurisdiction anywhere in
canada to seal off a city from people
driving any conveyance coming into the
city
one of the fundamental charter rights is
freedom of movement
so to deny freedom of movement
to people who are coming to express
their charter rights
i don't have a lawful authority that i'm
aware of to allow me to do that
i think you know as many as well as any
um that this is canada's largest
geographic municipality
i forget the actual number of square
miles but i am learning about all the
number of ways in and out of the city
including five provincial bridges
uh and the 400 series highways never
mind all the other roadways and byways
i would need a police service probably
the size of 50 000 to even begin to
attempt to do that even if i had the
lawful beforehand to do so
what we are doing
lessons learned from last week
and intelligence gathered during this
week is we are starting to curtail some
of those access routes so for instance
once we realize the amount of truck
traffic that was coming across the
bridges we closed the majority of those
bridges and the ones that we left open
we created a checkpoint to still allow
people to filter through who are
emergency service providers health care
workers city workers and other people
that we could verify
that doesn't block the foot traffic it
doesn't block all the other traffic
so
this is the conundrum we're in
there's no lawful authority to seal a
city
there is no practical capability to seal
this city the size of it
and if we were to do so and block every
truck that could come through here the
economic impact would be even greater
than what we've talked about right now
the impact of people trying to move and
support their businesses supply their
businesses would be would be almost as
if not more catastrophic than it has
been
so i know
as a leader in the city as someone
representing the voice of your
constituents you are looking for that
elegant simple solution
that particular solution is not one
that's available to me or any other
police chief in any other jurisdiction
we will do our very best to fine-tune
the traffic plan based on the
intelligence that coming in that's
coming in with the support of our
federal
provincial on both sides of the province
partners and our local partners as well
as the city of ottawa in terms of
looking at ways that we can guide trucks
block some access ways
we have hardened as you've heard trish
ferguson we've hardened elements of the
downtown
we're bringing in cement barriers we've
used uh snow removal machines up until
now they need to be freed up for the
snow that's coming in the next 24 to 48
hours all of those options are being are
being looked at
but there is no way that we can block
every truck from coming into any access
point in a city of this size i hope that
answers your question
we will move on to ward 4 counselor
curry you have a question
thank you very much
i i do want to thank everyone who's
given us enough information here for us
to realize just how bad the situation is
um i'm hearing that officers are tired
i'm hearing that snow is coming i'm
hearing that the snow uh vehicles that
we've been using need to be moved for
the snow
um i'm hearing it's costing us eight
hundred thousand dollars a day
and uh i'm hearing that there are a lot
of things that we can do in terms of
giving people phone numbers to make sure
they're reporting so i think i'm hearing
a lot of important information and i
guess i guess
i know what people in canada have asked
me and that is why are we not bringing
in the army if there are potentially
uh groups coming from the us
who has to make that decision who makes
that call and is that maybe not a
solution with you know the army has
vehicles
i'm hearing we can't block streets
um block access but you know the army is
an entirely different
group so i'm just wondering why are we
not contemplating that you say we are
not nothing is off the table
everything's on the table uh what would
it take for it just to be the army to
let any truckers that are coming this
weekend or groups of people that are
coming this weekend
that
this is going to be a different
situation this time
thank you councillor um spent a large
chunk of my day out in canada yesterday
uh talking with our public order
commanders
and in fact at that meeting as we have
over the last week we discussed the
option of military aid to civil power
i've said it again
we're looking at every single option
including military aid to civil power
i've had those discussions with mayor
council members the board
there is a process it's extremely well
established extremely well governed
and extremely rare the only two
occasions that i'm aware of
in the last hundred years was in the oka
crisis and in the flq crisis
one in the 1960s or 70s and one in the
1990s
um i have seen in my own policing time
in the u.n peacekeeping mission in
kosovo exactly how that looks when the
military are mixed in with police
and there are some amazing capabilities
that come with it and there are some
incredible risks that go with it as well
it is not a decision to be taken lightly
i'll say it again as i said before
every option is being looked at
none of the options create a beautiful
elegant simple safe solution they all
come with massive risks
that option in particular would come
with massive risks
military are war fighters and
peacemakers they are not peacekeepers
and they are not police officers
they have a different training and
equipment and mindset when it comes to
assessing threats threats to themselves
threats to others and they have a whole
different tool set and training set to
affect the mitigation if not the end of
that threat
and mixing them into a population in the
downtown core
in a highly volatile demonstration
without
any much more than days in advance
warning may mitigate some risks and may
create and escalate a whole bunch of
other risks
all options are on the table our lawyers
are looking at all of them our
commanders are looking at all of them
all of them come with massive lists
i hope that answers your question
well thank you very much
and we'll move on to board five
counselor al shantiri do you have a
question
good afternoon everyone so it takes time
to uh i'm not sure why the why don't you
put people in the waiting room instead
of waiting for each one to log on but
anyway i just want to say uh thank you
chief for your leadership and thanks to
everyone
the officers the bylaw everyone who has
to work all weekend and still working
one question about the cause we keep
hearing about the police cars we haven't
heard yet from
other costs bylaw services at public
works other paramedics on call fire on
call we haven't heard the cause of other
city services that's my first question
my second question is chief in the past
we had a working group working together
with the protester and perhaps you know
walking and driving the street together
to make sure
we don't hear those stories and and they
should be held responsible if they are
responsible for that demonstration they
should be on site to see a truck a block
in
a daycare they should see a truck
blocking people going grocery they
should see
what their their their
affiliation with with the demonstrator
are doing in our city and we haven't
seen this we've seen our city saw a
longer demonstration in the past but was
never
out of order the way we seen this one
here
thank you very much councillor century
um
i will i will leave it to um city
manager steve canalakas to to start to
pull together the totality of the costs
my chief administration officer blair
dunker is
uh is is factoring the cost specifically
to the ottawa police service that is the
number that we've seen between the 700
to 800 000 per day range
in regards to your specific question
around um whether we're using what i
think you're referring to as police
liaison officers who would normally
communicate with coordinate negotiate
with protesters yes we actually
significantly increased the size and
number of our plt officers and i'll
leave that to acting deputy chief
ferguson to speak to that in a minute
they've been fully engaged for over the
past full week once we transitioned from
an opp led
a negotiation to an ottawa police-led
negotiation we've actually sought and
received additional police liaison
officers from the opp we are bringing in
higher level negotiators to support
their activities i remind you and i know
you know this sir but i remind city and
council
this is a demonstration that has
literally hundreds if not thousands of
different groups
individual lone wolf actors local
provincial national and international
actors who are engaging online and on
our streets
we have through our negotiations been
able to establish a reasonable level of
communication and a modicum of
cooperation with a core group of the
original trucker
demonstrators but that does not account
for a large and diverse number of people
we're now finding that we've got
significant success in negotiating and
reducing the impact of the original
trucker demonstrators that's where we've
seen the largest number of trucks leave
and demonstrators leave that's where we
have the success in reducing the
footprint in the city the number of
noise coming from those elements where
we have little to no communication and
almost no ability to negotiate anything
is all of the ones and twos trucks and
suvs and cars and individuals walking
across the bridges and coming into our
city by any number of means from train
and plane an automobile and then walking
around in our cities and causing
disorder and trauma to our residents and
our businesses and that's been the
challenge that makes this unique and
unprecedented in terms of a
demonstration whatever we negotiate with
one group does not stand for all the
groups in this city and that has been
one of the huge frustrations and
challenges i will ask deputy ferguson to
speak to the role of the plt within this
current demonstration so far and any
additional information she may have in
that area
thank you chief and thank you councillor
el shantiri um our plt is the chief
alluded to we have actually increased
our team the size of it threefold and
since uh from
learning from other uh demonstrations
and how key those roles are and those
officers again have been working um
around the clock to establish
communications and i think the chief has
already you know spoken to
most of the aspects of it but there are
obviously some different influencers in
this and so while we are connecting with
the people on the ground um who are
identified as team captains for the
convoy and very much investing a lot of
time and effort in building those
relationships and ensuring that the
communication is flowing um the there
are a number of people who who are
hell-bent on
you know just causing disruption and and
they're not interested in negotiating uh
and so that makes that that position
difficult i do think um that we can
appeal to a number of the the team
captains because they they don't want to
a number of them don't want to sully
their name uh by some of the actions of
other fringe groups that are associating
themselves with them um and so your your
point is well taken and i will bring it
back to them and see if uh if that is
something that they are able to
incorporate in their in their actions
with them
thank you
thank you
and mr steve canelacos would you did you
want to address the citywide question uh
question about the city
thank you uh amy uh yeah it counts for
the um we have set up a cost center that
everybody's coding all their costs and
time to but i don't have a rolled up
number yet but we will have one i'll be
able to report out the council but we're
tracking um all of our costs across all
services
it will be fair to say mr kennel act is
more than just
seven or eight hundred thousand dollars
a day because once you factor the other
cost it's going to be a lot more than
just a police cost
oh absolutely i think the the numbers
are the numbers are going to
escalate considerably
okay thank you
thank you unfortunately we have to do a
hard stop i know there are many other
questions
um this is the time allowed we are
we have a 15-minute break and then there
will be a virtual media availability
yeah go ahead did we extend to four
o'clock members of council on the board
were all offered an opportunity to ask a
question even if the rapid fire if we
could get in as many questions as
possible in fairness uh to the board
members and council members i would
appreciate it
yeah chair um i appreciate that too i i
will extend myself however i'm going to
ask that we
allow
my commanders
to go back to doing the work that i
think everybody needs them to do so i
will do my best to answer the questions
without the support of trish ferguson
steve bell
blair dunker we actually have a lot of
police work to do and
every 15 minutes is actually incredibly
important so i will stay on and i'll
just ask the rest of my team with the
exception of amy to go back to their
responsibilities
yeah we'll do that um yeah go for it
mayor i think uh as eli suggested
there's any way of letting people in the
waiting room because there's
too much valuable time we're wasting
between so let's get people in the
waiting room and my colleagues if we
could be more succinct it's more a
question period as opposed to a speech
period thank you
yeah we'll work on both of that and just
for the next 15 minutes our sign
language interpreters uh need a break to
be able to
be able to interpret for the
media availability so there won't be
sign language for the next 15 minutes
that being said we will keep going then
with um
ward 6 counselor
counselor gower if you have a question
and if we could let
councillor kavanaugh in as well she will
be next
thank you very much
hearing language chief about holding
territory about foreign funding about
incitement of violence deputy chief bell
mentioned that one of the charges was
related to carrying a weapon do you have
any intelligence or reason to believe
that uh there are our firearms that
we're dealing with that kind of a threat
um especially with all the caution
around wanting to to provoke these
occupiers in any way
councillor gower thank you very much and
and i will be a bit rapid fire um yes we
have had indication around firearms
coming into this jurisdiction as part of
this demonstration from as much as a
week and a half ago in fact there was an
arrest made in the east coast of an
individual
who was threatening to bring a firearm
here and that interdiction happened
before they were able to get close to
ontario
we're aware of a wide variety of weapons
that have been incited to come into the
demonstration and quite frankly the
weapons of opportunity that are
represented by hockey sticks flag poles
vehicles themselves and trucks represent
probably the greatest and most imminent
threat that our officers faced every
single minute that this demonstration
has been weapons were used in the
demonstration vehicles were turned into
weapons and used as such in the
demonstration that took place in alberta
in the previous 24 hours that is one of
the major risks that we've been facing
and trying to mitigate at every point
throughout the pre-planning
through the demonstration and into this
period of transition and it will
continue to be a major risk for all of
our officers and the entire city going
forward
thank you chief
counselor kavanaugh and then following
that it'll be councillor cheerilee
thank you very much and i appreciate the
interventions of my colleagues and i
appreciate the the update overall from
from staff from the police and from city
staff it's about rebuilding trust the
the concern is and you're quite aware of
this and much of your presentation dealt
with it is the feeling that this is a
group that's being treated special
compared to other protests and that is a
concern
examples are um the parking
where a ticket can be issued this is
bylaw more than uh police but uh where
parking tickets are issued to regular
citizens and not to trucks blocking
roads and um i've heard some explanation
but i just want to pass on that's one of
the biggest concerns the other one um
i've had a report of bonfires at the
corner of of slater and lion um
and reported to 911 where it was told
that that was okay
and when they repeatedly call
that's where the 911 goes and that's on
social media so it it has an effect of
of of people not believing that the
police are responding to their concerns
and so
you don't have to address those
particular ones but i think there's an
overall strategy here that we need to
know that there is a response um i'm
hearing that the lines are open but but
those are the kinds of concerns that
we're hearing uh that create a feeling
that
we're not being we're not being
treated seriously thank you
thank you very much councillor i will go
back and have the records of our cad
calls coming into our police service
about bonfires be checked
if in fact that language was used we
will take we'll do an investigation into
the conduct and the processes around it
uh in regards to bylaw i will leave that
to kim yet to speak to that
sorry about that yeah well bylaw
continues to do uh everything they need
to do within or outside of the perimeter
outside of the red zone and within the
red zone they're doing it in
consultation with police and they're
doing their job so sorry counselor did
you have a specific question with
regards to bylaw
it's related to parking tickets why is a
truck not given a parking ticket yet a
citizen who just parks over time and
actually paid um is getting ticketed
yeah so all all activities outside of
the red zone are it's regular business
for for uh the citizens of ottawa and
that's where most of the tickets are
taking place the one ticket they're
referring to occurred on the market and
the market when they started collapsing
the red zone which is the area of uh
demonstration
the market was no longer in the red zone
and bylaws started to do their regular
duties in that area
there was another
two
social media accounts
relating to
people who had the same kind of
activities but they were nowhere near
the center town they were just
complaining that they actually got
tickets uh somewhere in the city of
ottawa when the truckers are not getting
tickets and obviously we're not going to
put our bylaw officers at risk by having
them go into
the hot zone and issue tickets to a
crowd that could become violent
okay so there's no police intervention
so there's no story let me clarify yeah
let me clarify there were there have
been 115 tickets in the red zone
but we pick and choose when we do that
and they're primarily for
people who are blocking the emergency
lanes people who are blocking
residential lanes where people can't get
out and people who are blocking fire
hydrants all public safety issues that
need to be addressed immediately so
there have been tickets issued and with
police escort
okay
thank you very much for your responses
thank you
we'll go to
councillor shirelli and then we'll go to
councillor
egl thank you um
i just noticed today uh just a month ago
there were people
asking for defunding of
police
and today the same people are upset that
there's not enough police presence
so
i think this is a good learning moment
for everyone about that
but my question would be regarding
the need to report
i know i've dealt with my residents many
times on the need to report and they
feel uncomfortable phoning in a
complaint
once let alone two three or four times
but
uh we really have to drive home the
importance of uh
doing it repeatedly if you see re
repeated
uh apparent offenses
so
i think that's important but the
question would be
is there anyone there who would define
since we were asked to encourage people
to report hate crimes
is there anyone there who could define a
hate crime
because it's not what some people think
it is some people think
if the person
is yelling out an opinion
counter to their own on masks or
vaccinations
that that constitutes a hate crime but
it doesn't
uh
it would be probably beneficial if
people knew what it really was
so if you have the definition that would
be good
thank you uh counselor uh in regards to
hate it must be again it must be
directed towards a member of uh
a group
identified under the ontario human
rights
uh so there's 14 prohibited grounds
vaccination status as far as i know is
not one of them neither is your status
of employment so i hate cops i hate
counselors i hate doctors doesn't
constitute
it can be an act or it can be an
incitement to act in a way that's
criminal towards one of those prohibited
grounds under the ontario human rights
code
um so i think that's probably the
easiest sort of layman's term that i can
provide at this time uh we will put out
through our social media uh the exact
definition and more clear examples so
that we can help the public to
understand what is and what isn't
um i would again encourage as you have
uh we need to know what what crimes are
taking place what hate crimes are taking
place and so we do want people to call
in
at the other end of the spectrum we are
getting flooded by a lot of nuisance
calls we're getting people calling our
911 communication center asking us if we
can find out where justin trudeau is
we're getting people calling in and
asking whether or not
we believe in vaccination status
so our lines are getting clogged up with
a lot of nuisance calls and our call
takers are trying to receive the
information that has the highest risk
and requires the greatest level of
service for us to deploy to that risk
so thank you very much for your question
i hope that goes some way to addressing
it and we'll follow up with more
information from the general public
around definitions and appropriate use
of 9-1-1 and 3-1-1 services
okay if you could
make it clear who those groups are it's
basically
race orientation and those kinds of
things right
yeah if we can keep to one question and
a quick one i want to get to every
member of council so please be
considerate let's go to keith now thank
you
thank you mr mayor and um i'll try and
keep it brief um as we only have the one
question i i guess this is for chief
slowly
what i'm hearing from my my residents is
the frustration with the situation that
we have now
with with how to get the trucks uh and
the truckers out of the core and the
question that a number of my residents
have raised is
why didn't we knowing they were coming
knowing they were heading for downtown
knowing they were heading for parliament
hill in the core
why didn't we take steps in advance to
divert them for example so that they
were diverted to a central parking spot
um weather or area like tony's pasture
or something and then
shuttle to the hill walk to the hill
take the bus to the hill
the problem seems to be fixing
the situation getting them out of the
core what if we had taken steps so why
didn't we take steps i guess is the
question to keep them out of the core in
the first place and still allow them to
protest as they're lawfully allowed to
protest
thank you very much councillor i think i
addressed this earlier on but i'll go
back to it again i'm not aware of the
lawful authority that allows me to block
i'm not as i'm not saying chief that you
should have shut up
shut access to the city what i'm saying
is when they were in the city to divert
them to a central location and encourage
them to access the hill in a different
way that didn't lead the trucks in the
core thank you very different question
thank you very much i was about to
answer that question but if you would
allow me to answer it i will
please do
thank you and that's exactly what we did
through negotiation well in advance of
their arrival to the city we recognize
that the crush of trucks coming in from
all the different directions literally
north south east and west that we would
have to be able to find large locations
where we could get them to park and move
without their trucks into the city all
of that was done it is all well
documented it was done through the
cooperation and the participation of
city staff and many trucks are in those
parking lots unfortunately many more
trucks came and we weren't able to
provide that as an option
we are not allowed to block the city off
even now the the red zone or the the
footprint we've established still has an
emergency services route that we're able
to get
fire ambulance and police services
through we do not have a full lockdown
in any place that would be dangerous so
again i know people are looking for a
simple elegant solution to a very
complex problem but that is not a
solution that was available to us we
have continually restricted access
points as much as we can without
blocking commerce emergency service
providers health care providers city
workers from coming and going into the
city and that will continue to be our
plan going forward as we try to restrict
access
for the for the main demonstrators and
the larger vehicles coming into the area
but what you're asking for sir was all
assessed all part of the planning for
significant success with it but we still
have significant problems as a result
chair deans you're next on the list i'm
not sure if you wanted a question if not
we'll go with a counselor to your knee i
i will pass thank you okay so it'll be
counselor tierney and then that
counselor king
great can you hear me okay
yes we can great thank you very much uh
thank you very much chief uh look um
i'm looking at the reluctance of calling
this uh an occupation
and i'm just curious why we haven't
actually said that this is an occupation
i see them with wood burning a pizza
ovens playing road hockey uh it doesn't
look like they're going anywhere it
looks like a tailgate party and i'm just
wondering is there a reason why we're
not calling this for what it is it is
it's an occupation uh is the
ramifications to uh changing the
verbiage thank you very much chief
thank you very much counselor i believe
um we actually have been talking about
this as a transition
and we use the actual term transition
from demonstration to occupation i
actually don't think that's even fully
accurate there's a demonstration that's
continuous and there are elements of
occupation that are taking place
increasingly as we transitioned out of
the core demonstration of thursday night
friday saturday and sunday negotiations
were clear
that the core of the trucker
demonstrations were going to be staying
they were going to be staying until they
had spoken to the prime minister they're
going to be staying for varying other
degrees around vaccination rules federal
and provincial and they were going to be
staying in some cases from
a large number of other elements beyond
the original trucker demonstrations uh
all the way through to an end of the
government an overthrow of the
government and i think you've all seen
we've all seen things on social media
so there is definitely a demonstration
phase that peaks and valleys and in
between there there are increasing
elements of occupation that are coming
in are we into a pure occupation no
we're not
it is a transitory period that's the
best i can describe it as
each of those definitions come with
risks and come with resource demands and
come with unfortunately implications for
businesses and residents in the city as
a whole
i mentioned again i'll mention it one
more time
um i am less and less convinced of an
elegant
effective police solution to this
there are going to have to be other
solution options that are are
significantly visited
and we've had a number of discussions
some of which you were involved with
around what are the roles of the various
levels of government elected officials
other statutes that go well beyond my
ability to engage in and well beyond my
resources and my mandate to engage
great thank you i'll let my other
members of council ask questions and
thank you very much chief
thank you so it'll be counselor king and
then we're going to counselor lieper and
just a reminder we do have another
nine counselors to ask questions please
make them short we want to get to
everyone and we do have immediate
availability after
so councillor king thank you
thank you chief you have indicated that
you're exploring different options
because as you had just said uh speaking
to counselor tyranny and others that
there might not be a policing solution
and we've heard that you've said that
you've been talking about injunctions
and military support to police services
uh i suppose for a plan of action to end
this demonstration uh and you've also
noted that uh elements of this uh
demonstration is transforming into an
occupation i'm wondering if you can give
us a timeline when we can expect a plan
of action and when that will be
communicated to the board the council
and uh residents to general public
thank you very much counselor
literally every day we do a threat risk
assessment
we get updates on the various plans and
options that we're looking at
and we assess to what extent they can be
implemented
i could probably tell you that if i get
the right option with the right risk
assessment we'll have a plan today
but if the situation changes as it does
literally on a day-by-day basis that
plan may no longer be valid as soon as i
have a definitive plan i will share with
who i can what i can at the most timely
opportunity
i may not be able to do that depending
on the nature of the plan
so i can't give you a definitive it's
one day it's two days it's one week it's
two weeks i'm not in a position to do
that
counselor leap followed by councillor
brockington
thank you very much uh chief i guess i'm
discouraged to hear uh some of the
comments around uh non-policing
solutions but more practically at the
moment uh with respect to the hotels has
work been done to try to encourage
hotels not to
um
accommodate uh the protesters who we can
expect this weekend i'm i'm very
concerned about what this weekend will
look like
thank you very much counselor uh we've
been a constant liaison with the hotel
association
uh there's a gentleman's name i think
it's uh ball mr ball who's been in
direct contact with
uh superintendent jamie dunlop and have
literally had hundreds of conversations
around this uh they've been very helpful
in terms of helping us to understand
what short-term and longer-term bookings
look like we were alerted to the fact
that they were seeing an increase in
hotel bookings uh for the for the
weekend coming up and we had that
information from even during the past
weekend so it was clear that we were
going to go in cycles of peaks and
valleys
um
they are a privately owned set of
businesses they have their own
requirements for profit making and they
have their own legislative restrictions
around who they can deny access to and
under what circumstances and i will not
speak for the hotel owners of the
association but they have been very much
involved in our planning risk
assessments
engagement around this entire issue
hopefully that answers your question sir
thank you chief thank you sir
councilor brockington followed by
councillor kluty
chief is the ottawa police service
responsible
for negotiating the end of a federal
political protest
or are there others that you look to and
expect
will be engaged to negotiate an end of
this occupation if people have driven
across canada
to come because they want to speak to
the prime minister or the leader of the
opposition and they're not meeting with
them
then what is the end game if people have
a political
protest political issues that's not the
ottawa police to solve so who's no who
is responsible
for negotiating an end
of this political protest and occupation
counselor brockington i can say sir
you've we've had some really engaging
conversations and you've raised some
very important questions
probably none more so than the one you
just wished
i will continue to look for the safest
most effective policing solution
possible with my partners at municipal
provincial and federal levels we
continue to receive significant support
from my policing partners emergency
services partners and let me again
include our city partners and my thanks
to steve kanilakis
but this is a global pandemic
that has resulted in a range of
municipal provincial and federal
rules and regulations and laws
and people across this country have
decided to come to the nation's capital
the city of ottawa to express a wide
range of frustrations
some specific to the pandemic
some specific to vaccination-related
regulations and laws and restrictions
and some just to express frustration
around government in general
nowhere in my job description and
nothing that i can find in the police
services act requires me by law
to negotiate the end of any
demonstration no matter how large or
small no matter what the reason is
the only thing i'm required to do is
provide adequate and effective police
services to the residents of the
jurisdiction that i'm sworn to serve and
protect and that is what i have been
doing from the day i took office and
will be to my last day in office i
stated again i said it before i'll state
it again
i am increasingly concerned that there
is no policing solution to this and that
other solutions are going to have to be
considered
well beyond my ability to dictate or
even influence thank you for your
question sir thank you
councillor klutzy followed by councillor
kitts
yes
thank you
chief
um what organizations are you working
with with respect to tracking the hate
groups and
um
nationalist white nationalist
organization or removing
and charging those uh bad actors
uh thank you councilor cliche uh we are
working with literally every municipal
provincial
police service in canada the rcmp
uh we have full cooperation and support
uh from csis
and our national security agencies
uh international security agencies
through our national security are also
contributing
um and as i said this is a local
provincial national now international
demonstration
and what happens in other parts of the
country and indeed in other parts of the
world have direct effect here so there
is a massive amount of intelligence and
information sharing taking place
and has been so from the very beginning
of the demonstration even when it
started on the west coast right up until
literally the question you just asked we
are sharing information in real time
hopefully that answers your questions
sir
well listen we'll hear from that
counselor kip and it would be kelter
roos i do not think he's
logged in so then we'll be going to that
counselor
thank you um we saw in a release from
ottawa police yesterday that it was
estimated that there were approximately
250 individuals involved with the
downtown occupation currently
are you telling us that there is no way
with your current resources and the ones
available to you that we cannot
end this before we see a resurgence on
the weekend
and
enable a situation where pro-protest and
anti-protest civilians are gathering
thank you for your question
counselor kitts
i can tell you that we are aware that
within the demonstration
core and fringe there is a significant
capability using old-school cb radios to
new schools social media platforms their
operating command centers locally
nationally and internationally to
coordinate activities there is
international fundraising going on the
level of organization funding and
capability around this demonstration is
probably one of if not the most
important factor that makes it unique
unprecedented and singularly risky in
every aspect
we have already seen in the last 24
hours that a much smaller demonstration
in a much easier to manage jurisdiction
within this country despite the best
efforts of intelligence gathering
investigation resource multi-joint
forces operations within minutes failed
to move a much smaller and simpler
protest into any better safety feature
this is not as simple as any other
demonstration that we'd like to believe
you've asked an important question it
just ain't that simple
thank you
counselor moffat followed
thank you by virtue of being number 21.
i have no questions that you haven't
already answered multiple times thank
you
we will move on to counselor meehan
followed by counselor hubley councillor
hublius uh had to go to an appointment
so he's not available
it'll be councillor meehan and then we
have a police service board member
nirman sueda and johnson as well as
smallwood
[Music]
i'd just like to i just like to offer my
thanks to everybody um
uh chief
you're asking residents in the downtown
core
uh to report incidents to the police or
incidents of criminal activity yet we
are hearing reports that uh police
officers are witnessing criminal acts
but have been told and i'm asking this
on behalf of residents who are talking
about this and
that somewhat the officers have been
told to stand by and not police those
incidents even though they want to for
fear of escalating the situation can you
address that are those rumors or is that
in fact a fact
well thank you very much councilman i
think uh from the briefings that we
provided the board last week and this
week
um that we were very emphatic we would
expect to see criminal acts taking place
online and on our streets
we would investigate every single one of
them and we would take it as far as we
possibly could to lay charges make
arrests if necessary and pursue
prosecutions we've been working with the
crown attorney from eastern ontario to
prepare for just that and we put
resources in place we also told the
board last week and this week and the
council and our media briefings that
there will be many instances where we
cannot intervene in the moment but that
does not mean we will not hold people to
account at any point in the days and the
weeks and the months and the years
following
officers may in fact have witnessed
criminal offenses taking place in front
of them if they did not involve an
immediate loss of life or risk to life
they probably would not have intervened
but would follow it by way of
investigations we're collecting
information by way of cctv camera
videotaping observations and witnesses
we encourage people to report any
criminal acts that we were not present
for or don't have sufficient with
evidence for but we are going to have to
make an assessment in every case whether
or not making arrests at that moment
will create a bigger public safety risk
than the crime that's being committed i
hope that answers the question it's one
that's been raised before and that is
the situation still to this day okay on
social media we're seeing trucks full of
diesel fuel canisters of diesel fuel
um is is this in fact um um
what can you get uh give us the risk of
the of danger of having these trucks
ready to fuel up
um
other trucks in the downtown core
i'm in the hands of the facilitator i
think that's an entirely different
question do you want me to continue to
answer questions posed to me
um i guess i'll just leave it then at
one question
thanks okay thank you that's it for me
then
thank you uh we still have four that's
our four police service board members so
we have member nirman then it will be
member sweda
member johnson and then member smallwood
so if we could give them all access to
be able to ask their questions and we'll
be able to move on remember we could ask
for quick uh
questions and quick responses because we
have the media availability they're
waiting for the chief and i and steve
thank you
all right
member nerman
uh thank you thank you everyone uh i
have already indicated most of the
questions have already been asked and we
were separately briefed so i have no
question i will pass but thanks for your
teamwork and the good work all all of
you are doing thanks maya thanks chief
thank you
cheer everyone
member sueta followed by member johnson
thank you uh likewise um all my
questions have been answered and i've
also had
debriefs
with the chief so thank you very much
and thank you chief and thank you to all
the obs
member johnson followed by member
smallwood
thank you chief and
all of the ops for all of your your
very hard work there is a
disproportionate impact of the truck
demonstration on individuals living in
the area of the demonstration
in particular
members of the bipark and
lgbtq2 community
can you please review the services of
the human needs task force
and how to access their services
and thank you again
i'm sorry i may have misunderstood the
question member johnson
am i to review the services of the human
needs task force
yes yes this is a services briefly
presented earlier in the meeting and i
guess i'm just highlighting again and
asking you about it but but i'd also be
happy if this information was just
released you know in a statement or on
social media as well that there is a
task force
at two one one and three one one that is
going to provide these services
okay
something from the city manager to do
yeah uh steve cadillac we have a
donna gray a general manager uh bev that
would be happy to brief the board on
uh at your next meeting or your next uh
briefing so
the chief could arrange that with steve
carlacas and it's she's very good
she's got a very good detailed list of
services provided for the most
vulnerable so thank you for that
thank you mayor
thank you and our last question will be
member smallwood
i believe you're on mute uh there we go
um
my questions have already been answered
thank you
listen uh thank you all very much um we
will have another technical briefing
before council
before next wednesday uh to keep you up
up to date and i know there's a council
liaison that everyone should have access
to that the chief has
created to help answer questions of
concern so we'll now adjourn for a few
moments and then for those parts of the
media we'll start the media conference
in a few moments of our call
to impress our kid community thank you
all very much